- [Announcer] This program is presented by
University of California Television. Like
what you learn? Visit our website, or
follow us on Facebook and Twitter to keep
up with the latest UCTV programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Jamal] First of all, let me thank you
all for coming. My name is Jamal Khokhar,
and as of three weeks ago, I'm the new
President of the Institute of the
Americas, having just finished five years
as Canada's Ambassador to Brazil. And I
have to say this is certainly not a bad
tradeoff, Lieutenant Governor coming up
from Brazil. The only thing my Brazilian
colleagues would tell me is that, "Yeah,
but do they play soccer there?" So we'll
have to work on that. Today's an important
day for all of us in the sense that we're
really using this opportunity to
underscore the importance of the North
American economic space and economic
integration. And whether you approach it
from the perspective of being a Mexican, a
Canadian or an American, or a Californian,
North American economic integration is an
absolutely key issue for all of us in
terms of prosperities and jobs. And today
we have no one better than the Lieutenant
Governor Gavin Newsom to speak to that
issue. None of this could take place
without our sponsors, and we're delighted
to have Debra Reed from Sempra here with
us. Debra, thank you very much for your
contributions. And Luis Escarano, Duty
Free Americas and UETA, our UCTV sponsor.
And without further ado, I'm going to ask
Chancellor Pradeep Khosla to introduce the
lieutenant governor.
- [Pradeep] Thank you, Jamal, and welcome,
everybody. UC San Diego is pleased to play
a key role in this 20th anniversary
celebration of SENTRI and I'm told a San
Diego innovation. When I think about San
Diego, I think about UC San Diego in
addition to other things, but I did not
realize until I got here three and a half
years ago that this was a San Diego
innovation, and I must say I think it's an
extremely impactful innovation. So it's an
honor to join our colleagues and partners
as we continue our collaboration to
enhance, as the ambassador said, border
innovation. I think one cannot understate
or overstate one as good and the other
cannot overstate the importance of
cross-border innovation. Okay. Are you
looking for votes here?
It's all right. I can help.
Sorry, sorry. I had to say that.
Typically... I'll get to that in a second.
He sits in the center seat at the Board of
Regents and he gets to pick on everybody,
so this is my chance to... Anyway, SENTRI
was born out of a series of discussions in
the early to mid '90s. This was a
discussion amongst university people,
business and civic leaders, scholars and
people who were in general concerned about
San Diego's future growth and prosperity
and quite like the roundtable discussion
we have today. So before we can get to
that, though, we are fortunate to have my
boss' boss. No, seriously. My boss being
the Office of the President and her boss
being a regent, and in this case,
Lieutenant Governor Gavin Newsom. He's our
keynote speaker and he is the ideal person
to talk about how California's future and
economy depend on partnership with Mexico,
as his key priorities are economic
development, job creation, improving
access to higher education, and bolstering
California's environmental leadership. He
has an amazing background, a background in
both private industry, having started 15
small businesses and created more than
1,000 jobs, and background in local
government. And we all know what he's
famous for. He was one of the visionaries
who saw something that many of us even
today cannot see, which is unfortunate,
but thank you for your leadership in that
area. And having served as supervisor and
later Mayor of the City and County of San
Francisco. Okay. So I've had the pleasure
of getting to know him through the UC
Board of Regents as he serves on the
board. He is one of the most articulate,
one of the most... How should I say it?
The ability to put complex ideas in very
simple terms and crisply interrogate,
investigate and get to the gist of the
conversation and really bring it back home
to, for us even as chancellors, think
about what is it that we are trying to get
the regents to approve. So with that said,
sir, this is yours.
- [Gavin] Thank you, Chancellor.
- Welcome.
- Thank you, Chancellor. Thank you very
much for the introduction. Jamal, thank
you for very much for hosting us and
organizing this event. And welcome,
everybody. Thank you for the opportunity
to be here in the governor's stead. It is
always good to have the governor out of
the State of California when you're the
lieutenant governor. So as your acting
governor today, let me welcome you on
behalf of a grateful state. You always
take advantage when the governor is out of
the state, and I will do so. Back not
until Saturday at 3:00, in case you need
me. Let me try to contextualize my
thoughts. I won't take too much of your
time. I'm here because we're all here to
celebrate leadership, to celebrate vision.
But we're also here to celebrate each
other and what I think makes us great. If
you're like me, it's frustrating picking
up the newspaper, listening to the radio,
watching the news with everything that's
going on around the world, in Syria,
what's going on today, and Putin's
bringing in drones and tanks into Syria,
what's happening with ISIS and what's
happening in Iraq and Yemen, around the
rest of the world, where nations and
people are literally being torn apart
because of racial, religious, ethnic
controversies, with field fanaticism and
field terror. But here we are in San
Diego. Here we are in one of the most
diverse regions in the most diverse state,
the State of California, in the world's
most diverse democracy, the United States
of America. And what brings us together is
a fundamental principle, a value that
transcends. And that is when we are at our
best, this is a state that doesn't
tolerate its diversity. We truly celebrate
that diversity. We celebrate, as Bill
Clinton would say, all our interesting
differences. But at the end of the day, we
unite around our common humanity, what Dr.
King talked so evocatively about. We're
all bound together by a web of mutuality.
We're all in this together. For me, that's
an antidote to the stress to the anxiety,
to the fear that a lot of us have. And in
so many ways, it's what we're celebrating
today is a recognition and an
understanding of that fundamental
principle that we are at our best when we
practice pluralism, when we strengthen our
connections, when we celebrate all that we
have to offer and unite around the things
that bring us together. That's exactly
what Congresswoman Lynn Schenk understood
in the early 1990's. And what a backdrop
the early 1990's in this state because
every single thing I just said, it wasn't
self-evident in 1992, 1993. It sure as
heck wasn't self-evident in 1994 in the
State of California. Xenophobia was raging
wild. The nativist attitudes were raging
in this state. The isolationist attitudes
were alive and well. We had a governor at
the time that was advancing something that
three out of five Californians embraced,
that proposition known as Prop 187. The
embers of that were being lit in 1992 when
Lynn became a congresswoman, 1993, and
ultimately advanced in 1994. The backdrop
of that time, don't forget, was not only
the xenophobia, the fear of other, but
this white fear that was being advanced by
politicians, that whistle we all know too
much about. They changed the language,
didn't they, at the time? They talked
about quotas, including chancellor quotas
that ultimately led to that same Board of
Regents of which I serve on had 14 of its
members to eliminate at this time
affirmative action at the UC system, a
price that is still being paid today, not
just here on this campus but all 10
campuses at the UC system. That fear, that
white fear that promulgated in other
efforts. Three strikes initiative.
Remember at this exact same time in
California a backdrop that is dramatically
different than I would argue that exists
today. How can that be? How could it be
that a young congresswoman could
understand that we could do more and do
better? How could it be that she can
partner with folks like Rudy Murillo,
connect the dots with some of our nation's
most prolific leaders at the time, Fritz
Hollings, Lloyd Bentsen and others in a
backdrop of a revolution that was about to
come with its leader by the name of
Gingrich about to ascend to that
leadership position to then advance the
same year the SENTRI Lane opened a
government shut down? How familiar these
words are in so many ways today. What an
extraordinary backdrop. See, what I admire
more than anything is leadership. We're so
desperate for it in this world. And one
thing I recognize, and Lynn recognizes
though she had formal authority as a
congresswoman at the time, but one thing I
recognize is leadership can come from
anywhere. When people recognize they have
agency, that they can help shape the
future. Even in a position of formal
authority, it was very unlikely that
Congresswoman Schenk would be successful.
Extraordinarily unlikely. So what she had
to do was exercise her moral authority,
and that's where true leadership resides.
It's that dialectic between those in power
and those outside of power, the
partnerships that are formed that push us
along to stand up on principle and do the
right thing. At a time when everyone was
focusing on what's wrong in Mexico, she
changed the conversation. She changed the
narrative. All of a sudden, Mexico wasn't
just about drugs and violence and
trafficking. All of a sudden, we started
looking at a hundred plus million people,
at least today, very differently. Started
thinking about Mexico in terms of
entrepreneurs. Thought in terms of
cultural identity, artistic excellence,
innovation. A country that today, over
half the population is under the age of
30. We recognized that true measure of
power is found in forming new connections.
That's real power. She practiced the art
of inclusion and created an on-ramp,
literally and figuratively, in a world
where everyone was trying to sever those
ties and create more off-ramps. It's an
extraordinary story. I know I'm here and
it makes sense that I say that, but it
truly is an extraordinary story. And one
thing we know in life generally, success
leaves clues, and the success of this
program 20 years ago has not only been
replicated through other ports of entry,
as you all know well, in California, but
in Texas and in Arizona. It's an
extraordinary example and an extraordinary
story. And so Lynn, I just want to say
long-windedly how proud we are of you for
your willingness to step up and step in,
to recognize that you not only had a voice
but you had an obligation to change that
narrative and to change the dialogue. And
we are all better off for it. I don't want
to overstate it, but I'm not going to
understate it. And I just think what you
did and what you accomplished is important
to memorialize at a time when those
nativist attitudes, those xenophobic
attitudes, are being revisited by folks
that are running for higher office,
talking about 1900-mile walls, talking
about dystopian state of police raids,
talking about taking children from parents
and ripping up the echo of Abe Lincoln's
contribution, the 14th Amendment. We need
to be reminded of what you all achieved 20
years ago and what we all stand for in
California and here in San Diego today. So
that's my message. It's one of gratitude
and appreciation, and I hope that we all
recognize that in this state, if we can
find a way to put aside those differences,
to reconcile those differences and focus
more on strengthening our connections that
there's no doubt in my mind, as the old
song says, "The best is yet to come."
Thank you all very, very much.
- So thank you, Mr. Acting Governor. That
was truly an inspiring and an amazing
talk. Thank you very much. Okay. So before
we begin our panel titled "SENTRI, Against
All Odds," I'd like to give a little bit
of a background on the efforts of an
extraordinary group of community leaders
who work with key government partners,
like Congresswoman Lynn Schenk, who we
heard so much about, in fact, I learned a
lot in listening to Gavin just now, and U.
S. Attorney Alan Bersin to make SENTRI
possible. So it all began in 1990, as we
heard, with the idea for San Diego
Dialogue, a series of discussions that
were happening right here, aimed at
identifying issues and strategies that
will enhance San Diego's promise. So UC
San Diego was a strong partner in our
community and a contributor to our
region's growth back then, just as we are
today and just as we will be tomorrow.
Innovation is in our DNA and we've always
had a mission of finding solutions to
societal challenges. So UC San Diego
played a leading role in the dialogue with
our community partners which led to the
consensus that San Diego's greatest
potential for growth lay in its proximity
to Tijuana, but the congestion and wait
times at the border proved a barrier to
border commerce and innovation. So of
course the story doesn't end there. And as
anthropologist Margaret Mead was spot on
when she said, "Never doubt a small group
of thoughtful, committed citizens can
change the world. Indeed, it is the only
thing that ever has." So our panelists
right now will share with you what was
done to work on those challenges and
hurdles to create SENTRI, including
Congresswoman Lynn Schenk's role at the
federal level to secure approval. And I
think nobody could have said this better
than Lieutenant Governor himself. So with
that said, I want to turn this over to my
dear friend, my dear colleague, our
well-known leader in the community,
somebody who knows everybody and everybody
knows her. Need I say her name? Mary
Walshok.
- [Mary] While everybody's getting on the
stage, our panelists, Lynn, I want you to
know that Kevin Faulconer declared today
SENTRI Day in San Diego. I know Lynn's
house. I know her office. I hope you can
find room for this declaration from the
mayor acknowledging the 20th anniversary
of SENTRI. And I'm not going to read all
the whereases.
- [Lynn] Good.
- But I think echoing Gavin's comments,
this was a pivotal moment in this region's
history and I think in California, and
it's recognized across the political
spectrum. And so congratulations, Lynn. I
hope you carry it home tonight.
- Oh, no. It's going to hang in Pradeep's
office.
And while Mary's coming up here, I just
want to re-echo the invitation I gave to
our lieutenant governor. I hope that
you'll speak at my funeral.
Oh, you're the emcee.
- So what I would like to do as a
beginning because of who's here in the
room, Lynn, is thank and acknowledge a
group of San Diego and Tijuana leaders
who, 20 years ago, began working together
to define where they thought the region
can go in terms of building an economy
that would be prosperous and equitable and
leverage the assets of both the United
States and Mexico. I'm only going to take
a moment because I really want the light
to shine on Lynn's work today because if
we hadn't gotten this legislation, nothing
else would have happened. But as of 1990,
people like Bill Rick, Bill Nelson, Mickey
Fredman, Brute Krulak (some of you
remember him), the editor of the Union
Tribune. Debbie and I were talking about
Tom Page, then the CEO of San Diego Gas
and Electric; the Chancellor Pradeep of
UCSD; Dick Atkinson came together to talk
about the leadership void in San Diego.
Thank you for mentioning leadership
because there was a leader waiting to make
things happen. And very quickly, those
roundtable discussions led to the
importance of our connection to Mexico.
And I remember Malin Burnham saying to me,
"If when I had joined this group, I had
thought I would be looking south rather
than north for our future, I'm not sure I
would have joined the group." And he has
become one of the most outspoken champions
of the integration of our cross-border
region, both socially and economically.
Mention was made of Dick Atkinson but also
Bill McGill, who many of you will
remember, who was the retired president of
Columbia University, chaired this group
and he coached Chuck Nathanson, the
director of the San Diego Dialogue, and me
on how to move an agenda forward. So this
organization was building a kind of
readiness in San Diego, and Lynn and I
have had animated conversations, a
readiness to make the border work if
someone could champion, as you described,
legislation that would turn the tide. And
that person was Lynn. So what we'd like to
do in this session is start with Lynn. Now
he stole some of your thunder, but I have
heard these wonderful stories over the
years from Lynn about how she, with the
help of Rudy Murillo, but also thanks to
Mel Katz and Chuck Nathanson coming in,
talking to her early in the process,
picked up this mantle and ran with it.
Laurie and I are here to be the local
yokel lore that is the context, what was
going on here while she was working in
Washington. And Sally is very important
because the legislation was signed... I
think it was January? August '94. But the
lane didn't open until November '95, and
that's where Sally's history and the work
of many of the people in this room kicked
in in a very important way in terms of
coming up with an approach to implementing
what then we called the commuter lane.
Trusted commuter lane? I can't remember
what we called it.
- [Sally] It initially had a lot of names.
- Yeah. It initially had a lot of names.
Sally is right.
- It was a DCL, dedicated commuter lane.
- Yeah. So with that, Lynn, you get to
start.
- Well, one thing. Laurie was my chief of
staff.
- This is why Laurie--
- And as every person who has a chief of
staff knows, including Gavin, they go
first.
- [Laurie] I don't want to go first. The
only thing I want to say is, Lieutenant
Governor, and you'll appreciate it, Lynn
was a freshman member of Congress. Okay?
Lynn was a freshman member of Congress. It
usually takes at least two or three terms
just to find the restroom. That being
said--
- I never found it. All right. Yeah.
Really, I feel like I'm at my own eulogy
or something. But first of all, to
Lieutenant Governor, thank you very much,
and your able aide here, Tracy, who got
her start with me. I saw her fine
fingerprints there and certainly Rudy's.
But thank you. Chancellor, thank you.
Ambassador, thank you for hosting this.
And for all of the men in the audience,
thank you for wearing a coat and tie on a
day like this. So you've gotten a lot of
the backdrop. Here, pre-1993 San Diego,
lots of things going on, business
communities. Certainly, the role of the
university and especially the San Diego
Dialogue, looking south, looking to what
is going on. Lots of things anecdotally
that we knew. Lots of things intuitively
that we knew. But the Dialogue, being an
academic institution under Mary's
leadership and Chuck Nathanson, the late,
great Chuck Nathanson, decided to get
facts and figures. And they came out with
a report of who crosses the border. Well,
again, for San Diegans it wasn't shocking
but for others it was. Ninety-seven
percent of those who cross the border both
ways do so for work, for education
purposes, for visits to family, visits for
tourism. In other words, for the everyday
of life. And what was the big blockage,
like a blockage in an artery? That was the
border. So we had Chuck and his group and
Mary's group coming up with all of these
wonderful public policy background papers
that are so necessary, as the Lieutenant
Governor knows, to implement, to get the
start in legislation. But there were other
things going on pre-1993. We here in San
Diego were represented by simply one of
the most extraordinary members of Congress
ever to have served, Lionel Van Deerlin,
and he represented the South Bay area. His
chief of staff was Rudy Murillo. Rudy was
very nuanced and knowledgeable in what was
going on in this area, and by the time I
got to Congress, Lionel Van Deerlin, then
had retired and Rudy was at what was then
called INS, one of the precursors to the
border and customs agency now. Rudy was in
that agency at a time when, coming from
San Diego, he knew what needed to be done
as well and he was looking for initiatives
to increase the number of inspectors not
for power purposes, but to open more
lanes. In fact, one day there was an
experiment and all 22 lanes were open and,
lo and behold, cars went through in two,
three, four minutes. So he was trying to
do that. There was at INS, and I don't
know if they were working with the
university but maybe, also sort of a
nascent approach to having a dedicated
commuter lane. So that was all there when
I took office in 1993. There were a number
of key turning points, and Laurie, as I
said, was my chief of staff. And unlike
most members of Congress, I had my chief
of staff in the community, in the district
so that she was in charge here and going
back and forth. So she really had her ear
to what was going on and had under her
some staff who she directed and she will
tell you. Jump in anytime you want about
this one. There was a young woman by the
name of Rochelle Roseman, Rochelle Bold
now, who would on a daily basis look for
initiatives. So we weren't going to just
be reactive. We were going to be
proactive.
- After 2:00.
- After 2:00. Yes.
- After 2:00, we learned from the
congresswoman, you put down the react file
and you go to the proact file.
- Well, Rochelle came across this
interesting tidbit that in Blaine,
Washington, there was a commuter lane to
Canada. And she brought that to Laurie,
and Laurie got in touch with Rudy because
we were all friends. If you take away
anything from this, and I'm just going to
interrupt myself, and those of you in
government and politics will know this to
be true and maybe even in academia, it's
luck and it's who you know and it's the
relationships that you develop. It's
something that, at least today, robots and
machines can't do yet. It's coming but not
yet. So my staff and Rudy, lots of back
and forth, and lo and behold, one day I
get a call that Chuck Nathanson of the
Dialogue wants to come and see me and Mel
Katz, who was then just I think cycled off
as president of the local Chamber of
Commerce but was on the Dialogue board,
that they wanted to come and see. And they
came in with this proposal for a dedicated
commuter lane as one tool to ease the
congestion at the border. Well, sounded
great to me, sounded great to Laurie. See,
we were so naïve in the ways of
Washington. We had no idea that there was
this huge artery blocking, roadblock, by
the name of Congressman Jack Brooks. Jack
Brooks, may he rest in peace, I love the
guy. He was just like he could have played
himself on television. Congressman from
Texas, Chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee. Very powerful. Very powerful
committee. Jack had a personal bias, shall
we say. Am I saying that diplomatically,
Ambassador? A personal bias against a
commuter lane at the southern border so
much so that the pilot project... And if
I'm going to get too deep in the weeds,
just yawn or something and I'll get the
message. The pilot project at the norther
border was expiring and there had to be an
appropriation to continue it. So the '94
appropriations bill, which was written in
'93, extended the pilot project in Blaine,
Washington and specifically in language in
the bill prohibited one at the southern
border. So not only do we have a
congressman who was opposed to this. We
got a law against it. All right? So we
proceeded to write the legislation. The
staff and myself, we write the
legislation. Meanwhile, locally, Laurie is
gathering up the support, the business
community, the Dialogue and another very
key player. And you're going to hear
names, and I'm not namedropping. I'm
giving due to the people who made this
happen because when something is
successful, there are a lot of parents.
It's only failure that's an orphan, right?
So there were a lot of parents to this. A
key person was then the U. S. Attorney
Alan Bersin. With a less visionary U. S.
Attorney, it could have been dead on
arrival. But Alan embraced this. He
endorsed it. He became really like a
cheerleader. He and Laurie locally talked
to everybody that needed to be talked to
and then some, especially with local INS
and Customs. And Sally was there. You'll
remember, of course, that more so at the
federal level than the local level, there
was pretty strong opposition from INS and
Customs to have a commuter lane. So
anyway, Alan agreed to get on board and
Laurie created a local task-force, a
commuter... What did you call it, a
commuter task-force?
- Yeah. It was under the offices of the U.
S. Attorney's Office and the Congressman's
Office, so it was both.
- So I chaired it, Alan co-chaired it, and
there were regular meetings. So what came
out of this was that we would bring...
What?
- Go ahead.
- That was later. She's still telling me
what to do, and I still have to listen. We
wrote the legislation and introduced it.
So the task-force was created January or
February of '94, and by that spring we had
some legislation that would overturn the
prohibitive language in the prior year's
appropriations bill. I can't believe I
still remember this. All right. So Jack
Brooks was not amused. And as Laurie
pointed out, I'm a freshman. Freshmen get
maybe one priority in a cycle, mainly
none, but this was one of my priorities
and I wanted to get this done. So on the
floor of the House, Congressman Brooks
very sweetly and in a charming way told me
that it was going to his committee and it
was going to be assigned to a subcommittee
that will kill it. So I have a little
hearing impairment and sometimes when I
hear no, it sounds like yes. And I know
Laurie has the same kind of an impairment.
So we said, "Oh. Okay. We're going to
figure this out." But we didn't know what
to do. So I pick up the phone and I call
Rudy Murillo, and Rudy just hates this. He
loves to be behind the scenes.
- We tried to get him on the panel. He
declined.
- Go step out or something. Anyway, Rudy
became absolutely the genius that I let
out of the bottle there, the adviser that
I needed on the strategy, what to do, how
to do it. Now there is an old saying that
if you have a weak stomach, you do not
want to watch how they make sausage or
laws. So now you're eating lunch. I'm not
going to get too deep into my recipe for
the sausage, but suffice it to say that
Rudy had two very important pieces of
advice. One was that INS and Customs had
to get something big out of it. That meant
money. That meant more people. That meant
facilities. All right? And the key was
introducing another person into the
equation, and that is a senator from South
Carolina by the name of Fritz Hollings. In
the '80s, I was very involved... And
Republicans, you can plug your ears, but
you have one of these committees, too. I
was very involved in the Democratic Senate
Campaign Committee to elect United States
senators, and so a number of them and my
friend Bill Lerach here was very involved
with me in that, and Sol Lizerbram. And we
elected a lot of U. S.senators. In fact, I
knew more senators than I knew members of
the House at one point. Fritz Hollings was
one of them. But more important, he was a
friend of Lionel Van Deerlin and Rudy
Murillo. Now why is he important? Well,
Senator Hollings was Chair of the
Authorization Committee, the Senate
Commerce Committee. But even more
important than that, he chaired the
subcommittee on appropriations on commerce
and the judiciary through which these
monies go. So basically Rudy was, and I'm
going to be very blunt here, counseling an
end run around Jack Brooks in the House
Judiciary Committee. A very risky move but
as I say, we were naïve and we said, "Oh,
that sounds like a good move." So we met
with Senator Hollings and he, because of
Van and Rudy, agreed that if we could get
it in the House Appropriations, that he
would be inclined to support this in the
Senate. Lots of back and forths. Staff
talking to staff behind the scenes. And
Laurie knew more about this than I because
she was part of it, talking to the House
Appropriations Committee. Meanwhile, we
got other people involved. I think the
Chancellor or maybe you, Gavin, mentioned
Lloyd Bentsen. Lloyd Bentsen was a former
United States senator from Texas and was
at this time the Secretary of the
Treasury, under which Customs resided.
Now, Lloyd Bentsen loves San Diego. He
spent a lot of time here. He had a home in
Rancho Valencia, and he and his wife B.
A.and my husband and I would socialize. So
when he was here one time, and Bill, I
think it was at your house that I hit him
up for the dedicated commuter lane and he
said he would see what he could do with
one of his departments, that is, Customs.
Meanwhile also, we had a friend in the
White House, and it wasn't the President.
John Emerson, who is now our Ambassador to
Germany. Anyway, so John, a Californian,
again a friend that we could call on, we
wanted to make sure that he got the
message to Customs and INS and others and
to Congressman Brooks that the White House
was supportive of a commuter lane at the
southern border. So all of this is going
on. Meanwhile, Alan Bersin invited Janet
Reno, his boss, the U. S. Attorney, to
come to San Diego. You want to comment on
that visit because you were very involved
in that?
- I will when we talk about collaboration.
But everybody who was anybody that needed
to be at that meeting at the border was
there. From the business community, from
the Dialogue, from the university.
- And we did a very large forum from
Teresa with her, which many of you may
remember.
- Coincidental with that visit.
- It was very powerful.
- But here's just a little tidbit. So in
Washington, Janet and I lived in the same
apartment building, right off Pennsylvania
Avenue. She liked to walk to the Justice
Department. I would take a bus up to the
hill but I would walk with her to the bus
stop. I did this because she had this
phalanx of security guys in cars behind
her. And so I ran into her in the hall one
day and said, "You're getting this
invitation from the U. S. Attorney in San
Diego. Here's what it's about." And it was
wonderful because to have the Department
of Justice, under which INS resided at the
time, be supportive was very, very
important. So meanwhile, we're pushing
this and the outcome of it, and I will get
to the point here, the outcome which was
very important: The House Appropriations
Subcommittee Chair agreed to put in what I
called wishy washy language, but it was
enough. It wasn't going to overturn the
prior year's appropriation but it was
enough to get it over to the Senate, where
it landed in the office of none other than
Senator Hollings, who immediately amended
the appropriations bill to overturn the
restriction on a southern dedicated
commuter lane and to appropriate funding
for one here in San Diego specifically.
What this meant was now it could go to a
conference committee between the House and
the Senate conferees. And meanwhile, Jack
Brooks is getting calls from the White
House, from Dianne Feinstein who we
engaged, getting calls from Lloyd Bentsen,
from a whole variety of people that he
rethought it. And one day, I got the word
that he would not oppose the conference
language being changed to the Senate
language, and that's how we got that. And
he wanted to deliver this message to me
personally in his office. I was not asked
to sit down. There were a couple of things
on his agenda, shall we just say, that he
needed some votes on in the future. So the
local paper said that I outmaneuvered one
of the most powerful people in the House.
It wasn't outmaneuvering. It was
collaboration, it was negotiation, it was
cajoling, it was not giving up, and it was
just plain old-fashioned horse trading and
being very lucky. I often say I'd rather
be lucky than smart. And I'm not very
smart so I have to be lucky. And it was
just a lot of luck of the right people
here in San Diego, in Washington, the
people who knew one another being knitted
together. And in August of 1994, President
Clinton signed the bill. So it's a
long-winded way of saying what happened
over a two-year period.
- Fantastic story.
- Twenty years ago, 1995, correct? That's
when we opened the door. But prior to
that, I would say about maybe eight months
prior to that, they started to assemble a
team of officers who were going to work
and design the enrollment center for a
dedicated commuter lane on the southwest
border. So we just had to basically put
our skills that we used every single day
on the border as officers: our
interviewing, what we required of people
when they came across the border. And we
didn't change that. We just stuck to those
basic functions that we perform every day.
We did not want to make it the impossible,
but because we were initially in a test
phase, we did have to be very cautious on
how we rolled out the program. We did not
want the program to fail. We received our
marching orders from our district director
at the time who was Mr. Mark Reed. I think
Mr. Mark Reed should get some credit also.
And Rudy Murillo was his chief of staff.
Right, Rudy? You were Mr. Mark Reed's
chief of staff or special assistant to the
district director in the INS days. And so
I was an INS inspector who was assigned to
the initial team. I think we were four.
There were three male officers and one
female, I'm going to have to say that, and
I was the lead. Thank you very much.
And I just have a question. What kind of
communication devices were we using 20
years ago?
- [Male] Yeah.
- You took my line. No cellphones. No
cellphones.
- No cellphones, right? So you can only
imagine what type of technology was rolled
out 20 years ago for us to deploy or put
together a dedicated commuter lane. So on
the way here, I was telling our DFO, Mr.
Flores, and our port director at San
Ysidro, Mr. Aki. I had totally forgotten
about the first fingerprint system that we
received at Otay Mesa. It was a state of
the art. It was probably the size of three
huge commercial freezers.
But we were so excited because we never
had this type of technology before, and so
we were getting all of this what we
thought was... It was brand new
technology. For 20 years ago, it was the
best technology that was out there. And
so, using the technology 20 years ago,
working with the two contractors--there
was EDS and SAIC, one for hardware and one
for software--and working with the
community, we couldn't have done it
without the Otay Mesa Chamber, the San
Ysidro Chamber, our Mexican partners. I
recall myself going over to Tijuana
weekly, monthly to give presentations
about SENTRI or the dedicated commuter
lane, giving presentations to the
maquiladoras. And so with all of that,
putting all that together and then coming
up with those first 500 businesspeople
that were going to assist with the test of
the concept on the southern border. And
then Otay Mesa, of course, being selected
was huge for us. You mentioned "Against
All Odds." We had some of that internally
also, right? We had to change the mindset
of our officers, of our partners there on
the border. And so I think one of the
biggest challenges for us was that we were
going to have this lane and the people
that were going to be using the lane were
trusted travelers. We had set the
parameters. You couldn't have a felony.
Misdemeanors, it was going to be two. You
had to have employment. You had to cross
the border frequently initially. And so,
with all of these things set into place
and discussing them with the officers
because the officers had to feel
comfortable. That was a huge challenge is
that those officers that were going to be
manning the lane had to feel security,
that it was a secure lane, in order to
have an expedited crossing. And so lots of
discussion with the officers. And so
initially built into the program were what
we call random compliance. How many of you
here were one of the first 500? Anybody?
Wow. Great. Okay. So you remember that
initial compliance. Okay. So with 500
people, you had people going into
secondary. Well, the officers said, "No.
We want to see them more." So we changed
the compliance rate. "Okay, we'll make it
higher." So we made it higher, requiring
the users to go into secondary more. A
couple of weeks later, they said, "We're
not catching anything. Lower that rate.
You're just creating a lot of work for
us." So we went back and forth with a lot
of that dialogue internally with the
officers. And so me being one of those
officers, it had a negative tone to it if
you belong to the dedicated commuter lane
staff. And so you were kind of like the
enemy because you were going against what
was traditionally the standard for working
at a port of entry. And so we proved them
wrong real soon because there were no
apprehensions. And so as people continued
to go into secondary, everyone was
compliant. And shortly after that, we went
from 500 to 2000 to 5000. Expansion to San
Ysidro. Expansion to Texas. Expansion to
Calexico. And so, the concept did not take
long for us to demonstrate that San Diego
was definitely the right location to test
the concept and then expand further. And
so very happy that I was part of that and
to see it 20 years later.
- As my good friend Laurie Black says, "It
takes all kinds of leadership." It takes
leadership at the national level, but I
think we just heard an example of
leadership here at the local level. Thank
you for that. So Laurie, you get to
editorialize now.
- Oh my God. I love editorializing. Jack
Volante, the late Jack Volante, if you
remember, he used to represent the motion
picture industry, about 24 years ago
introduced Lynn Schenk and he said, "In
politics, there are two kinds of people,
two kinds of horses. There's work horses
and there's show horses." And boy, don't
we know those show horses who watch the
Republican debate. I don't care. My
Republican friends were mortified. Lynn
Schenk is a work horse. She's a work
horse. It's one of the reasons I wrote to
her back in 1979 when I was in college and
said, "Whatever you do in life, I want to
be a part of it." And when she decided to
run for Congress, I had a 10-week old, a
2-year old and a 4-year old, and I
said, "Don't do it." She said, "I'm doing
it." And so we did it and it was quite the
ride. But the best part of working with
Lynn is that we worked with the community.
And as her chief of staff, so you keep in
mind the politics, this was not a safe
seat. This was an even-steven
Republican-Democrat seat, the new 49th.
It's very important you know that because
in 1992, what was very helpful was that
Ross Perot ran and took 29% of the votes
so it allowed our democratic friends to
win. And Bob Filner and Lynn Schenk, two
democrats, won.
- Don't say that name--
- I am going to say something.
Let me just go back to work horses and
show horses. I think it's a part of the
story. Bob is nowhere on this thing and
he's district representative, for God's
sake. So excuse me. It is for the record,
right? The other thing I want to make a
point of. We did do this and this is
really important. We did this without
cellphones, smartphones. We were just
getting computers in. This was about
relationships, and it hasn't changed in
our community. When we get things done,
like the library and like Petco and North
Embarcadero Visionary Plan, and I could
keep going through, those are all
collaborative efforts with elected
officials and with community, with
business groups and the very level. I mean
community groups want to be here but the
community groups who really know what they
want their neighborhoods, their villages,
their cities and their counties to look
like, and that's really what this was
about. But somebody has to be the leader,
the leader that we can depend upon because
we can't always depend on the leadership.
We had two things we used to say in the
office. Like "Milk does a body good, " I
came up with this right after Lynn won and
I said, "Lynn Schenk takes care of
business." I'm sure I got some look from
her. "Yeah, right." I said, "That's what
we're going to be." And we went to the
Chamber of Commerce. I had never been to
the Chamber of Commerce building. I was a
little younger than Lynn but I was still
over 30. And we walked in and Gil Partida
was the new president. Remember that name.
We had a Hispanic President of the Chamber
of Commerce, and Mel Katz, a Jew, was the
head of the board. I mean, "Oh my God."
But I realized we got things done. These
weren't people who were show horses. These
are people who wanted to do something. And
then you take a visionary like Chuck
Nathanson and you add that vision into it
and you take somebody like an Alan Bersin,
who along with Lynn, two of the smartest
people I know on the planet Earth. Alan is
working in Interpol today, representing
our country around the world for this
president. And so you have all of these
legal minds. You have lots of color in the
room. That's not the kind of thing we were
seeing because of the xenophobia of
Proposition 187 which passed in 1994. So
all I can say is from my two years, there
were a lot of things that got accomplished
during the two years of a freshman woman
member of Congress. She was the first
woman south of L.A. Some people will look
at me and say... I'm sure you get this.
She does, too. She says, "Once you're a
chief of staff, you're always a chief of
staff." So between Governor Brown and
Governor Davis, she nails me because I'm
still the chief of staff after all these
years. But it was such a pleasure and an
honor to be a part of it. I think what's
also very important in contemporary world,
I had a baby, a two-year-old and a
four-year-old when we were doing this. We
were changing diapers on Lynn's desk when
she was in Washington. And you know what?
That was okay because she wanted me there.
We had a serendipitous relationship. And
between myself, Rochelle, Bill Bold and
others who are still some of the smartest
in our community, with Lynn's leadership,
we could really depend and do some really
great things. And whenever I go through
there, I think of you and Jack Brooks. He
was tough. So thank you very much for the
honor of being here today. Chancellor,
thank you for watching my daughter. And
Lynn, thank you for being my sister, and
Mary, in life. I am grateful.
- Thank you.
- [Debra] It is my great pleasure to be
here on the 20th anniversary of SENTRI. I
think the mayor misnamed the day because I
think it should have been named Lynn
Schenk Day. How many of you agree with
that? Yeah.
When you hear the story of what was done
to accomplish getting the SENTRI Lane in
place, it tells a lot about the people.
But I know Lynn because she's on our board
of directors. And so what we just heard
about the relentlessness and the continued
effort to get something that was
unachievable or seemed unachievable done
is so much about this person. And it just
did so much for our region to be able to
have a flow of traffic across the border.
And here we are now, 20 years later,
looking at how we improved the flow of
traffic across the border so that people
and cars can flow as easily as energy does
across the border as our company works
with many of the Mexican utility
companies. So it is my great pleasure to
have Lynn come up and join me. Yep. I'm
not acting as Chair of the Board today,
Lynn. But it is my great pleasure to honor
Lynn in the 20th anniversary of SENTRI and
all of the work that she did to make this
happen for our region. So please join me,
and a round of applause for this wonderful
lady. Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪